another thing to think about as students  head back to class  school zone and crosswalk safety police  departments from all across the valley  held a pedestrian enforcement event  yesterday  near rancho high school and two other  schools a lot of time has passed  since kids have been around school  campuses and police tell  us drivers and pedestrians both have  picked up some pretty bad habits over  the last year  so far this year we've had 38 fatalities  for pedestrians so those are just people  who are out you know walking riding  their bikes  so we just really need to remind  everybody to please slow down pay  attention and  to the pedestrians out there also we  always like to stress  use the crosswalks they're here for a  reason  the traffic enforcement team yesterday  made 62 stops they gave out  60 tickets and clocked one car speeding  67 miles an hour  in a 35 mile zone wow